welcome back everybody i'm here with ed
helms and i'm skeptics
what was that i didn't do my favorite i
went
it was like a sad version oh well we're
a little tired today
um whenever we have an ad on the show we
like to play a little game called
never has ed ever never
has it ever good job jess
we've played it with comedy legend ed
asner and now it's time for new comedy
legend ed helms
so the game is simple when i say go our
super computer will randomly generate
something that ed helms
has or has not done emily and i get to
interrogate ed a little
then guess if he has or has not done
whatever is on the board
so whoever guess is more right is the
big winner here we go roll it
okay never has ed ever puked between
shooting scenes then he's in a movie
called the hangover
i mean are you really professional at
work do you drink on the job
i am extremely professional and uh
i don't drink on the job you don't drink
on the job
unless it's required unless it's
required i'm going with you've puked
between shooting scenes
[Laughter]
is that what you're going with okay have
you ever done that
okay yes i have puked uh
horribly between scenes but not because
i was drunk
but it was during uh hangover 2
production we were in bangkok thailand
and i happen to get the the worst most
violent food poisoning i've ever had and
as emily can tell you
when you're working on a movie it
doesn't stop no matter
what you got to keep going and so oh
they're like pull out the diapers
yeah yeah so literally
uh we're shooting this like riot scene
and i'm like
yeah and then i would just go curl up in
a ball and barf in the gutter
and uh bradley and zach were so sweet
and brought me
sprite and like petted me while i was
curled up in fetal position but it was
it was very
very touch and go for a couple of days
there barry the show must go on
yeah i'm saying yeah and the and the dp
the next day
he was like wow i didn't even know you
were sick oh that and i was the biggest
compliment
yeah you are an amazing actor that's
what it is um okay well let's go again
let's roll it
so never has ed ever had a fear of
clowns i
really hope you have a fear of clowns
i i just have to go with i mean the odds
that you
have had a fear of clowns are greater
that i i just i'm gonna go yeah that you
have
i don't know i'm gonna say that you have
never had a fear of clowns
yeah because you can tell i'm like a
tough
guy right are you serious
no i don't i don't have a fear of clowns
oh
i'm amazing i love clowns me too i mean
i i don't
certainly certain clowns pennywise
very scary but but not they're not
automatically scary to me
okay i do uh i do have an irrational
fear
of um mice really yeah i
people think they're so cute and like
people even have pet pet mice and
and like i recoil there's something in
my
there's some very primal thing that i
cannot handle
amounts oh my god i think they're so
cute as tough as i am
cinderella yeah tough as i am um well
okay round three roll it
all right you gotta get this one wrong
never has ed ever played a doctor in
real life
well i think maybe that's
more just sort of like like you know was
like
did doctorly things in a situation not
actually like pretend not actually lied
and said i was a doctor
okay so i just said that to see if you'd
give me the information so i'm gonna say
that you played a real doctor in life
that was my way no you're very happy
with that
i think i have to do the same but i'm
gonna go with
yes yeah i kind of spilled the beans but
yeah you did i just got it out of it
yeah you're so
clear you got me kelly clarkson okay
what's the situation yeah so
this was another like adventure trip
that i went on in my 20s
and uh we were i went on a surfing i'm
not a
much of a surfer but i went on a surfing
trip with some friends
to indonesia and we were way out in the
middle of nowhere like a full day's boat
ride
from the nearest like anything and
uh and my friend crashed on a surfboard
and basically tore his kneecap off and
it was flopping around
oh my god i was like very on it
we got him back on the boat and like i i
washed the wound and i was sort of like
you know you know helping him out and
keeping things calm and then all of a
sudden
i went into shock and i got
woozy and blacked out and i became the
medical emergency
in this situation so i was trying to be
tough
i was trying to be a doctor i was trying
to beat like rise to the occasion but i
don't i just don't have the constitution
for it
apparently oh my god i love that you
ended up like stealing the thunder and
yeah he's got his
kneecap hanging off that sounds so gross
um okay
just um winner is that's me emily
it's me no it is lovely to see you emily
i'm such a big fan of
everything you do oh definitely thank
you guys yes silly girl
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever